maintenant vous avez connu le meilleur
de la ville le pire vous savez tout mais
non on sait jamais tout
je vais déclaré au journal elle je me
suis enfin trouvé ah oui complètement je
crois que il y avait un côté de moi qui
était enfui qui est revenu à la surface
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je sais que
je suis on va en parler caramelder
interviewé
[Applaudissements]
alors Karen Mulder aux côtés de Naomi
Campbell de Cindy Crawford de Claudia
Schiffer de Linda Evangelista et de
Ellie McPherson vous avez été donc une
star des podium vous avez fait la une de
tous les grands magazines du monde
c'était l'époque des top model qu'est-ce
qu'un top model avait de plus comme
mannequin normal en fait c'était un mot
qui est tout d'un coup et remonté à la
surface et tout d'un coup on était plus
des mannequins on était des top models
et je crois que c'était les filles qui
étaient vraiment sur le devant de la
scène qui était pas seulement des des
filles sur des couvertures mais qui
convoyaient à la télévision connaissait
leur nom leur vie en fait la célébrité
quoi alors ensuite vous avez quitté le
métier vous avez fait des voyages aux
Caraïbes vous avez fait la tournée des
vous avez fait des tentatives
déjà pour enregistrer un disque et pour
jouer la comédie et puis un soir ici sur
ce plateau vous avez craqué c'était en
fait des choses qui sont remontées à la
surface qui ont fait que tout d'un coup
il y avait de la paranoïa en plus mais
il y avait des choses vraies ensuite
vous avez passé trois mois en clinique à
lutter contre la dépression et
aujourd'hui vous êtes de retour et vous
dites je me sens une autre femme toute
neuve la même en mieux
on change un petit peu de personnalité
je crois quand on va chercher très loin
dans soi mais on est toujours la même
personne mais oui mieux je suis plus
serein je vis plus l'instant avant
j'avais toujours tendance à les regarder
en arrière d'être nostalgique ou avoir
toujours un but de regarder vers le
futur et aujourd'hui je vais vraiment au
jour le jour quoi est-ce que cette
souffrance vous a endurci est-ce que
vous sentez plus forte qu'avant
moi je crois toujours être quelqu'un de
très fort d'un côté et très fragile de
notre la souffrance vous a appris la
compassion ma souffrance est toujours
été là pendant ma vie c'était quelque
chose dont je luttais constamment contre
donc je suis toujours été quelqu'un qui
avait eu beaucoup de compassion
est-ce que les psy vous ont vraiment
aidé dans cette affaire j'en ai vu des
des abrutis excuse-moi le mot aussi ah
il y en a vraiment ils ont rien compris
du tout et là je oui j'en ai un que je
vois de temps en temps je le vois même
pas souvent parce que j'ai plus besoin
mais j'aime bien de temps en temps pour
remettre les pendules à l'heure et oui
quelque part aussi ce qu'on a manqué
dans son éducation ou que la vie nous a
pas appris eux ils voulaient
juge pas au moins il écoute ce que vous
lui dites ça on peut dire n'importe quoi
alors vous êtes passé de l'autre côté du
miroir vous savez maintenant que le
bonheur n'est plus obligatoirement lié à
l'argent à la gloire à la vie facile
mais peut-être à l'amour c'est un amour
détaché au moins c'est un amour ou
on s'approprie pas quelque chose ou
quelqu'un c'est quelque chose de plus
spirituel pour moi
j'espérais rencontrer l'homme de votre
vie quand même
j'y pense pas oui parce que si vous y
pensez ça va vous obliger à vous
projeter dans le futur
et puis il faut pas avoir une idée trop
trop préconçue non plus il faut pas
avoir une idée en tête parce que sinon
on est plus disponible pour les hommes
qui peuvent arriver bah oui c'est vrai
que par la solitude des fois on fait les
mauvais choix on préfère être avec
quelqu'un même si nous convient pas tout
à fait parce qu'on veut pas être seul ou
des choses comme ça oui
quel type d'homme vous cherchez je
cherche pas
quel type d'homme vous aimeriez
rencontrer alors
j'aimerais quelqu'un
je trouve ça très difficile peut-être un
homme tout simple
vous voulez avoir des enfants ah ouais
j'aimerais beaucoup mais pour ça il
faudra quand même que je trouve cet
homme ça vous demande un effort d'être
là ce soir non non
très la dernière émission je vais pas
faire du tout de venir ici
non mais c'était vraiment très aimable
de l'avoir diffusé c'est la moindre des
choses
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu